vavoua cette présentation saison
2020-2021 molière les femmes ou encore
le swing voici les grandes lignes de la
saison culturelle 2020-2021 aux clayes
sous bois
elle a été lancée en grande pompe samedi
19 septembre à l'espace philippe noiret
au programme de cette année de l'humour
du théâtre de l'art vivant ou encore des
concerts cabaret une saison qui
s'annonce éclectique et chargé malgré
lakovic 19
l'enjeu il est multiple puisque il faut
déjà pas perdre notre public
le public existant et fidèles qu'on à
chaque année lui permettent de pouvoir
revenir dans les meilleures conditions
qui soient
malgré les contraintes sanitaires est
toujours le même enjeu c'est faire venir
le public qui ne se permet pas dans mon
corps de venir dans les salles de
spectacles en plus d'une présentation
originale de la saison culturelle la
municipalité a profité de cette soirée
pour inaugurer l'exposition arts
numériques de l'artiste nouvelle manque
les siennes marc flou et passe du oui
entre art et science
il n'y a qu'un pas on désire en fait
c'est de faire vivre des de l'émotion de
faire voir les choses autrement de
questionner nos relations nos
perceptions de nos environnements
changer un peu la vision des choses par
le biais de ma vision à moi qui ai
souvent oniriques
c'est vraiment utiliser des outils
technologiques sommes vraiment des
outils pour créer de la magie et mettre
en mouvement en fait des objets des
images faire intervenir le sont donc on
retrouve tout ça au coeur de
l'installation sous forme un petit peu
de cabinets de curiosité et pour mieux
appréhender lèvres de ma flow est pas
doué
son exposition est à découvrir à
l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois jusqu'au 20 octobre